[Music]
and Jesus shoes news
Jesus Jesus was submitted by diet coke
diet coke that's Steve's diet that's
these drink well so his monster $3,000
Nike sneakers injected with holy water
sells out in minutes is this holy water
a little bit about this but I don't know
too much what do you know about it Shawn
holy water like in these tubes and you
just see the holy water like cup that
has like makeshift water in the outside
rim of the cup yeah so the water is
supposedly there's 20 cc's of allegedly
water from the Jordan River blessed by a
priest okay inject it into the shoes
okay and it's by this brand called
mischievous CHF it's called the mischief
X like INRI Jesus shoes she better make
me walk on water you say that this Bible
verse right here Matthew 1425 is the
verse where talks about Jesus walking on
water how did the Catholics feel about
this wow these are more Christian
apparently these are more Christian
symbols yeah get right pass Oh read
supposed to be a like a god of Jesus
blood or something clearly they sold out
on him so I don't think Kristen's made
this I don't think they made him know
what I'm sold on this because uh
what about it where that's right it's
right behind booyah what do you want the
smarter you so much as I was saying I'm
sold on that idea because if I were to
ever walk into a haunted house I will
feel protected I would never walk in a
haunted house yeah big brain time so
less than two thousand pairs were
released on stock X only Oh at a price
of three thousand each
Jesus little G I know right
take Lord's name in vain on this one oh
you can still buy them loaded you could
buy a pair from anywhere from auctions
from two thousand thirty nine hundred a
pair damn would you what is that
something that you guys would buy never
understood that whole world of buying
shoes I mean like I get to like though
like buying and then reselling it but
like I know people like collecting so
Daniel Greenberg the head of Commerce
for mischief the company who decided to
do this actually admitted this is just
like a gag thing to kind of highlight
the absurd like culture agriculture or
collab culture so you got someone like
Street where like has the where's
collaborations ever like supreme makes
like flashlights to like bricks to like
oh hey those are cool buzzers yeah
they're cool business has supreme on it
so they're just kind of like here oh
it's blessed with holy water it's a
parody of that type of Cola not apparent
if they sold out in they're profiting
off I feel like they probably don't
broke even though I feel like what the
amount of work they probably went into
making them it probably just claimed
that [ __ ] they don't they don't have to
actually get holy water they can just
claim it to me that they did it this is
assuming that they went assuming that
they actually like they just broke even
just for the [ __ ] of it yeah
he said the influence is from if you
guys don't know when adidas collab with
Arizona iced tea
I don't you guys see that one likely
remember if a big company adidas could
you know collab with a tea that's been
being sold in bodegas in New York and
then cents then we can do holy water
shoots and see this how absurd you know
it can get yeah and it worked but how
did the Christians feel about it I mean
I'm sure the old type of way above of
this I think this is this a gag and it
worked how do they feel Nike is not in
any way attached to this project really
a showing is the creator Christian no no
like well I don't know
so the only other thing an article tells
me the guy had a commerce said this is
just like merely a gag to see he says
he's Jewish
actually big irony that's that's
literally like him just [ __ ] not
wondering what would a collab with Jesus
Christ look like oh my god Jewish man as
a Jewish person must by itself the only
thing I knew was that he walked on water
Jesus I'm gonna get wrong that's why no
no I'm gonna get it wrong that's
something that we should all speak our
mind about religions that we don't know
exactly no repercussions no controversy
let's talk about politics too [ __ ]
[ __ ] no [ __ ] yes [ __ ] here [ __ ] your
room to my commands like 45 40 bucks you
know yes the holy water wasn't it and
they only made like 2,000 these how much
would that be how much would they go for
there's no holy water yeah with no holy
water likes to just say it was just a
normal as it collectible to 300 isn't it
300 those 3,000 I forgot just for the
sheer fact there's like less than 24
pairs you know that's like values that
hide yeah as a collector's item there's
a limited supply no cuz they're in that
culture there are people that are
willing to get it just for the fact that
it's that limited oh yeah yeah I mean
it's like collecting like anything else
I mean like people collect weird [ __ ]
I'm like people collect stamps and say
yeah true but at the same time I feel
like because like this was
my can you forget when was in it was
Nike it was Nike shoes I feel like if
fear at God came out with something like
this like shitstain fear of God t-shirt
only 10 made in the world people would
buy oh yeah yeah so you guys see the
water it's like it's like that actually
looks a lot cleaner than I thought it
would be I thought that was gonna be
like unpurified like it leak water
something like that just have like all
these little things it's gotta have like
some dye in there I think it just might
be the actual light it's blended color
and gel yeah
so if vampire killers get this and they
slip that open and they shoot it at the
vampires or some [ __ ] yeah their feet
are protective yeah you didn't say
you're always walking on water 60cc
sorry oh well in that case goddamn
dollars Jesus Carl you asked me earlier
how much have like you guys paid for a
pair of shoes before like the what's the
highest okay well somebody has a big
question
Yomi asked I asked that I was looking
this direction I've highly paid the most
I have a pair of work boots from Red
Wings that I bought for about $300 but
those are like like an investment in
like you know all those work boots that
I've seen yeah yeah the ones with the
steel toe yeah Co toe and like I know
I'm not supposed to wear them for like
extended periods of time but I mean like
I've just grown to like like
form-fitting yeah and it's like really
good quality of a shoe and it's like you
can replace the soul as like much as its
ran out and read Redwing uh does this
program where it's like you could take
it in once a month and they'll clean and
polish and shine your shoes for you for
free you just pick it up the next day
it's like those moments of boots sure
sure but that other than that like I've
not spent more than like $40 on a pair
of shoes it's pretty reasonable
influence all you guys survive more
expensive shoes no hang on you guys I
want to spend money
ha sneak your head crazy like oh I have
to have all these shoes like I I don't I
don't understand that culture but to
each their own right I mean it I don't
understand holy water it's like well why
would you be spent on a single pair of
shoes then was it the people let me tell
you about holy water you're not so
putting shoes - paddle ya supposed to
and yeah I spent like 220 on those
awesome bad okay I've never bought shoes
for resale value em you're gonna wear
him right away yeah I think the most
expensive pair was probably like 125 but
that's like running shoes and
cross-country high school but it was
very little bit for a very practical
reason yeah if I think for fun I think
the most I spent is probably $70 I don't
remember what it was probably commerce
something else conference well you also
run your shoes into the ground that's
true you rub you you've worn a bigger
hole in Roshi's than I think I've ever
seen anywhere oh yeah there was two and
one oh no I had you bought in your shoes
and I was like Julie just just for the
other shoe thing no I am [ __ ] wasting
a cent on a running gun I had a pair of
black converse that I just loved to
death because it was black canvas the
star was pink and then the line that
they had on the bottom was blue and the
laces were yellow it was like almost
primary colors yeah I really enjoyed it
right and I I had hold all over on the
bottom and I think I started ripping a
little bit at the front and my mom hated
me like like wearing these shoes I was
so messed up so I think one day I went
off to like a trip somewhere and they
want to go visit my friend somewhere and
when I came back and I was looking for
those pair of shoes my mom was like oh I
threw them away and I was like oh why
would you do that because I
before picture and I really wanted an
after picture before I got rid of it but
it was already gone look great and also
when they're worn - [ __ ] they look great
yes yeah yes nothing in between
[Music]